often when we think about the beginning
of American history we think 1776 with
the Declaration of Independence or maybe
1492 when Columbus arrived in the
Americas but the history of America
really begins about 15,000 years ago
when people first arrived in the
Americas in this video I want to provide
a very brief overview of native
societies before contact to give you an
idea of just how diverse and complex
these societies were as Native groups
adapted to and interacted with their
environments
now there's recently been a scholarly
debate about how people first arrived we
know that maybe 12,000 years ago during
an Ice Age the sea level was lower and
so a spit of land in between the
Americas and Asia was exposed over which
people may have traveled but recent
archaeological evidence suggests that
people were perhaps already in the
Americas at the time of this Ice Age
so it's possible that they may have come
earlier in boats now however it was that
they arrived they spread north and south
and east throughout the Americas so that
by the time that Europeans arrived in
the late 1400s there were perhaps 50
million people that's kind of a
mid-range number for the estimates that
historians have made living in the
Americas and of those four to six
million we're living in North America so
how did these societies develop well a
really big moment was around 5000 BCE
when people in Mexico
domesticated corn maize as it's also
known and domesticating maize meant that
people who had originally been hunters
gatherers following herds of animals
could partake in settled agriculture so
they could develop villages complex
societies this isn't to say that they
stopped hunting or gathering but they
began staying in one place so let's zoom
in a little bit and take a look at some
of the major societies in these regions
Native American societies developed
around their natural environments using
the resources that were available to
them
for example the Southwest Plains and
Great Basin quite dry a lot of desert
and so societies in these regions
adapted to the dry climate in several
ways for example Native American groups
that lived on the Great Plains continued
their hunting gathering way of life
hunting bison and following the herds of
animals in teepees sure dwellings that
were easy to set up and then take down
people in the southwest like the
ancestral Pueblo in people dealt with
this dry environment by creating very
complex irrigation projects so that they
could water their maize crops using what
little moisture there was the Pueblo
winds lived in large cave complexes as
agriculture allowed them to grow their
population in the northwest fishing in
the Pacific Ocean gave Native Americans
a plentiful source of food while farming
allowed the Mississippian peoples to
develop large settlements like Cahokia
near modern-day Saint Louis which at its
peak may have had as many as 25 to
40,000 residents the Mississippians and
other East Coast native peoples relied a
lot on what's known as
three sister farming in which people
would plant corn beans and squash
together which was mutually beneficial
to all three plants as the corn served
as a trellis for the beans and the
squash protected the root system of the
corn all three together create a very
nutritious diet which allowed for a
relatively high population density on
the East Coast so by the time that
Europeans began to arrive in the late
1400s and 1500s native societies had
been evolving for over 14,000 years but
the introduction of European people
pathogens plants and animals would
introduce an unprecedented amount of
change in the Americas